I felt bad about something you were
you're you're fantastically talented and
and very handsome husband nick offerman
from personal creation there he is
[Applause]
experiencing transcendent joy but he was
nice enough he called my wife and i up
and he said i'm throwing a surprise
birthday party you know for megan and
out love you guys to show up and we
couldn't be there we missed the surprise
part we couldn't go to the surprise part
so we showed up later on and from the
sound of it the surprise part was
incredible it wasn't just her a surprise
and some balloons i really missed out on
something pretty cool well first of all
ever since we met i literally asked him
to give me a surprise party and it's
been 12 years and i sort of given up so
i this year i didn't think it was gonna
happen and I was supposed I was in
Oklahoma and I was supposed to come back
on Friday and that was the night of the
party so he planned it for like straight
from the airport at so the party was at
starting at 5 o'clock which is weird on
a Friday and then I had to come back a
day early because there were electrical
storms and an earthquake simultaneously
in Oklahoma and I was like I gotta go
so I came back like came back a day
early and it threw off the whole plan so
on the day of the party he said hey you
know let's go to a movie and I was like
alright so we go to this afternoon movie
and then Nick is pretty like you know
spit-spot Mary Poppins like once it's
done he wants to get in the car and go
home and he was really dilly dallying
and he used the men's room and he's just
walking like really slowly and then we
had to stop he said that we one of the
tires was low and we stopped at a gas
station and then he pulled over to take
a call he pulled over to take a call
from somebody at work and it's like yes
yes oh yes mm-hmm and I was like wow
what is going on with Grandpa over here
so
so then then we we get home and we we
you know girl in the garage and we have
a little way to get in the house through
the garage and we walk in the door and
he says have you pooped yet today
well I know why and he said because I
think you're getting ready to what and I
turn the corner and there were like 80
people and they yelled out surprise
mother
[Applause]
and then like these two big muscley guys
and loin clogs came out holding like one
of those seats that's just like there's
no legs on it's just like a chair like
you carry it and they're like sit down
so I sit on this chair and they carry me
through the two aisles of gas and
wherever we get like near the master
bedroom they're like look over there and
I look over and this friend of ours
who's really really funny named Rob
Huebel is on our bed and he's being
double-teamed by somebody wearing a
giant bunny outfit and somebody wearing
a giant bear
he's it is under reason his little
underwear and he's being double-teamed
by two plushies and then they're playing
basketball my mom's watching two points
and and then then they took me outside
and we have this little pool and it is
pretty little and in it was floating
there's this clear plastic bubble with a
beautiful girl dressed as a fairy like
floating in the pool and she's doing
like fairy things and and then they took
me there like put your feet up and I put
my feet up and they took me down into
the pool around the ferry up and out and
then there these five you know like at
the gas station or the car you know
automobile car walk car wash no you know
they have those plastic things with the
hair on top and they're like a little
face and they in you know rainbow colors
and a mariachi band is playing la
Cucaracha
[Applause]